these are the top 10 craziest moments
these are media moments they are
political moments these are clips we
have shown you throughout the year we
went through a whole i mean i assure you
to whittle it down to just 10 with some
of the idiocy that is on msnbc in the
view and a whole bunch more
um
it was not easy uh but uh here we go so
we're gonna do the top ten moments
you're gonna remember some of these some
of them you may forgot and some of them
you may wish you forgot here is number
ten
in massachusetts right now
those
crisis pregnancy centers
that are there
to fool people who are looking for
pregnancy termination help outnumber
true abortion clinics by three to one we
need to shut them down here in
massachusetts and we need to shut them
down all around the country
you should not be able
to torture a pregnant person like that
man i know you guys remember that one
because we played it a couple of times
and it was only a couple weeks ago and
you should not be able to torture a
pregnant person like that you shouldn't
be able to torch a pregnant person
that's what we call a woman right and
having a baby usually most women uh say
that's the biggest blessing in their
lives that this is the most wonderful
thing they could possibly do and what
that woman wants elizabeth warren that
crazy communist who is worth millions
and millions of dollars who sends her
kids to private school while she's
against vouchers and all of those things
what she wants is dead babies she wants
a lot of dead babies and a lot of dead
brown and black babies actually
um she's a bad bad woman i don't like
her very much and uh hopefully that and
that's the last time i have to think
about elizabeth warren for the summer
here
is number nine
fifty thousand ukrainians will be dead
or wounded yeah and that this is going
to start a humanitarian crisis a refugee
crisis in europe we're talking about
five million people
that that are going to be displaced i
mean
it's it's heartbreaking to hear what is
going to happen yeah well i'm scared of
what's going to happen in in western
europe too yeah you know you just you
plan a trip you want to go there i want
to go to italy for four years i haven't
been able to make it because of
of uh the pandemic and now this you know
it's like who's gonna what's gonna
happen there yeah
i mean of all of the clips of the
insanity on the view right like this was
a nutty week for the view this week with
joy behar and whoopi pretending that
there were nazis at the turning point
event whoopi basically denying the
holocaust that it had anything to do
with race like of all of the insane
things that they have said on the view
that one really holds a special place
that they're talking about the war in
ukraine and the five million refugees
and the lives lost and all of the stuff
and joy can't go to italy
where is joy behar gonna get her
mushroom risotto she'll have to keep
getting it on the upper west side of
manhattan that poor woman i mean really
just the the myopic
self-absorbed
insanity of the modern liberal is so
perfectly encapsulated by the once sane
joy behar
here's number eight
my mother drove us and rather than us
able to walk
and guess what
the first frost you know what was
happening
it had to put on your windshield wipers
to get literally the oil slick off the
window
that's why i had so damn many other
people i grew up have cancer
and why can't for the longest time
delaware had the highest cancer rate in
the nation
so that was about two weeks ago is the
president of the united states
announcing that he has cancer having
something to do with an oil slick way
back when and uh the reason i thought
that one was funny is because for only
five minutes did people care that the
president of the united states said he
had cancer because pretty much everyone
said no no no it's not that he has
cancer it's that he has dementia so
let's just let it slide
the white house issued a statement
saying that it was actually just he
screwed up the tents he had cancer
meaning he's had some things removed he
does not have cancer but it was just
like a perfect example of the nonsense
from this administration this guy
who can't do these anecdotes right
anymore who can't read these things
right anymore he thinks he has cancer he
doesn't know where he is you know it's
just
absolute insanity with this guy and
again will he be president when i get
back i suppose we'll find out here's
number seven
president biden he is saying he's going
to run again in 2024 will you support
him
yeah you know i think we should
endorse when we get to it but i i
believe that the president has been
doing a very good job uh so far and um
you know should he run again i think
that i you know i think it's it's
we'll take a look at it
for right now we need to focus on
winning a majority instead of a
presidential election so the reason we
wanted to throw that one in and you know
i take no great pleasure in showing you
aoc videos and trust me there's a
million things we could have shown you
of her doing something stupid is there
was something bizarrely refreshing
about aoc going on cnn and basically
being like no we're done with biden and
that's why she's laughing as she says it
because she knows it but she knows she
can't fully say it yet but there was
something kind of honest and refreshing
about that and the other thing is that
that was an interesting moment because
that was about a month ago now and that
was right when suddenly if you remember
before that nobody in mainstream media
was talking about what's wrong with
biden right nobody was saying it yes
here we're saying it online shows you're
saying it rogan's saying it shapiro's
saying it you know you're probably
saying it in your in your own circles
but aoc did that and then it was one of
those airlock moments you know how we
have these weird airlock moments where
we all know something's true but for
some reason it can't get through
mainstream media oh could there be a
wuhan lab leak everyone's talking about
it online for two years then finally jon
stewart goes on colbert he says it and
then everyone can start talking about it
right hunter biden laptop we're all
talking about online but nobody's saying
anything then finally new york times two
years later says something now
everybody's talking about it that was
sort of an airlock moment aoc we're all
talking about something's not right we
buy it and aoc goes there laughs about
it
boom now everyone's basically saying the
democrats are done with him and his time
is up so he's dead man walking i just
thought that was an interesting sort of
seminal moment
number six
it's independence day so let's talk
about what's going on in america freedom
it's under attack in your state
republican leaders they're banning books
making it harder to vote restricting
speech in classrooms even criminalizing
women and doctors i urge all of you
living in florida to join the fight or
join us in california but we still
believe in freedom freedom of speech
freedom to choose freedom from hate and
the freedom to love don't let them take
your freedom paid for by newsome for
california governor 2020.
oh
the blood could boil even though i don't
live under that guy anymore i mean
really the most evil person in american
politics today
and that's why he's the perfect democrat
and that's why he probably will be the
nominee after biden because that's how
this thing operates that the fact that
that swarmy slimy soulless
vapid nothing that he dares even say the
word freedom
uh is is so vile he hates freedom uh all
you guys know all the stuff that he's
done and all the lockdowns and the
destruction of california and that about
300 000 people have fled california and
they've come here nobody we couldn't
find it we scoured the internet could we
find one nut bag who moved from florida
to california in all of these last years
we couldn't find any u-haul can't get
trucks to go back that way they go this
way so u-haul is hurting he's the number
one u-haul salesman the guy is just
absolutely the worst he lie every single
thing he said in that video was a lie
that they're coming for freedoms and
they're banning books in florida
nonsense actually in cali they're
banning books because of words they ban
to kill a mockingbird in some california
schools because of certain words they
don't like they're not coming for gays
in florida he's just absolutely awful
you get it
number five
the diversity of this community
as distinct as the bogotas of the bronx
as beautiful as the blossoms of miami
and as unique as the breakfast tacos
here in san antonio
is your strength
of course that was a couple weeks ago dr
jill biden who you always have to
mention she's a doctor otherwise you're
racist uh dr jill of course who clearly
has not uh examined her husband uh she's
also not that kind of doctor but let's
put that aside uh just the endless
pandering
the reason that that video went viral
because it was just the perfect example
of the endless pandering that the
democrats do much like hillary clinton
what does she do she keeps hot sauce in
her purse right remember that she keeps
hot sauce in her purse when she's
talking to black people because black
people must like spicy food something
like that these people are just terrible
and they're and they're getting hit with
it at the end like it's finally coming
around where every time they do one of
their their pandering moments joe biden
you know trump's gonna put you back in
chains and they use their fake accents
when they're with these people and all
of these things it's like people are
seeing it they're so seeing right
through it it's just spectacular am i am
i under assault right now is the
internet coming for me uh these are not
sponsors of the show i don't know what
those things are
number four
uh can you provide a definition for the
word woman
can i provide a definition no yeah
i can't
you can't
not okay this context i'm not a biology
of the word woman is so unclear and
controversial that you can't give me
a definition
what a moment i mean that that in some
ways we could have put that as number
one but i think you're gonna dig the
number one but that moment when katanji
brown jackson who is now a supreme court
justice could not say what a woman is
and people kept saying oh it doesn't
matter it was a loaded question
and it's like well actually look at all
the gender stuff that has even exploded
even more in the say two months since
then right now and and when you don't
know what a woman is then you don't know
what a recession is and you don't know
what basic math is these people do not
want us to know anything that we do know
that we have always accepted as true and
that in some ways is the most seminal
moment of the year you know speaking of
our background freaking out a second ago
i should tell you guys one of our little
surprises for you when we get back in
september we're going to have an all-new
background
you guys are gonna be doing work i'm
gonna be laying at the pool but you guys
are me busting your asses working in
august here's number three
there was no mental health issue with
the individual who stole the futures of
19 children in uvalde texas all the
crazy things that that woman has ever
said
joy reid and joy reed is a racist and a
buffoon and just
total clown and all that stuff and
there's all these rumors that msnbc's
going to get rid of her but the the
knee-jerk defense
uh by the mainstream media and by people
like her to say
that this is only about guns that these
shootings are only about guns i mean her
implication right there i mean really if
you really think about it the
implication this young man goes into
this school he shoots 19 people i think
it ended up being 17 kids and two
teachers if i'm not mistaken he had no
mental health issues
by definition if you do that you have
severe mental health issues i cannot
imagine there is a psychologist
or a psychiatrist on earth
that would say if you shoot all of these
people unjustly you murder in cold blood
all of these children you have no mental
health issues it's it's that is insane
she has mental health issues truly i
truly believe that that is a woman with
serious mental health issues but because
they believe in narrative over reality
right they believe in narrative over
fact she needs to throw out that because
what does she want to happen when
someone gets shot it's immediately well
how can we do this to infringe on other
people's rights how can we come for guns
what can we do politically
to have more power over people
but again in the theme of today and
these throwback clips it's like more and
more people are seeing it more and more
people are seeing that gavin newsom's a
liar that elizabeth warren wants to
murder babies that these people have no
basic understanding of our rights or
anything else
and here is number two
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
man
i mean sad right like it's sad again
like i'm not a biden guy i don't like
what this guy's done to the country i
don't think he knows what he's doing or
where he is half the time but that
disrespect
that shade thrown by obama who i regret
voting for twice i really regret i think
barack obama has turned out to be an
absolutely uh terrible uh
terrible person he's just he's just
everything that i'm pushing against
right um the smugness like he knows they
don't just let people touch him right
people aren't just allowed to touch him
he knew that the president's hand was on
his shoulder there and he didn't care
that [ __ ] eating grin
while he's ignoring the president and
kamala ignoring the president abiding
not knowing where to go or who to talk
to and it's like who's in charge right
we always say who's really in charge and
maybe we got a little glimpse of it
right there as to who really is in
charge because who seemed more in
control of that room right there who
were people excited to see right there
was it joe biden hey where am i someone
talk to me brock brock or was it the guy
[ __ ] eating grin i mean that's the
definition of [ __ ] eating grin as he is
ignoring the president of the united
states and this one so you may ask well
that joy read one that i showed you
before
some of these any any of these could
have been number one but this is the one
that clearly is number one and you will
understand why
it's just such an unbelievable
moment
brandon you also told me
as you can hear the chance from the
crowd
let's go brandon brandon you told me you
were gonna kind of hang back those first
two stages and just watch and learn what
did you learn that helped you there in
those closing laps oh my god it was uh
learning how each line didn't uh
stay to one it everything shifted top to
bottom so much that it was kind of like
okay let's just stay patient where we're
at and hope it's just so perfect so in
case you forgot that was back in
september right and that was the moment
that that kid brandon nascar driver
brandon
he's being interviewed and everyone in
the crowd is chanting [ __ ] joe
biden that's what they're saying but the
media runs cover so instead she took
[ __ ] joe biden and she turned it into
let's go brandon and it became a meme
and it's on t-shirts and everything else
uh by the way we're gonna give away a
couple of these too today for people
that sign up if you go to
reubenreport.com support you will get
three months off an annual subscription
and we're just gonna send out a whole
bunch of shirts and a whole bunch of
reuben report shirts uh and much more
but that really is the moment of the
year that really is the moment of the
year because that meme
it captured a feeling it captured what
we were all trying to say but couldn't
quite figure out how to say it maybe a
little whatever and and it was funny and
irreverent and then of course the media
started running all these stories that
people who say let's go brand that are
white supremacists and all the stuff
but also having the media cover for him
it was that to me is the moment of the
year so since last september uh to right
now that really really was the moment of
the year